you've learned poi wraps now what comes
next drex here from drexfactor poi
sharing with you the love of boy
spinning and flow arts to benefit your
body and brain and today i'm showing you
some things that you can do once you get
into wrapping those poi around your body
parts before we dive in i just want to
give a quick shout out to the friends of
the channel big thanks to dark monk flow
fests flow toys juggling calling
pyroterra light toys spin balls and
ultra poi for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all of these amazing
businesses and what they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that i have down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to non-business friends
of the channel johnny howard and lane
mochinski thank you both so very much
for your support from my work and my
mission so i think i have a story that's
going to sound familiar it starts with
somebody who's learning a poi trick they
put in a whole lot of work on it takes
them could be several hours several days
several weeks and then they have a
breakthrough they can do the trick and
then they look at all the other tricks
out there and realize
i'm gonna have to do that all over again
fear not there might actually be some
stuff that you can pick up now that
you've already accomplished that one
trick generally speaking most poi tricks
have a lot of variations on them that
you can fairly easily access once you
get the basic trick down that's the
purpose of this series it's what comes
next and it's how i can help you get
just a little bit more out of the work
that you've already done and this video
comes as a request from keith
wychekowski i don't know i'm definitely
not pronouncing that right but keith
wanted to see a video dedicated
specifically to raps which i think is a
fantastic idea i don't often talk about
raps on this channel which is a little
strange because they were a big part of
my early poi journey this was really the
first method that i found to switch
direction to the poi before i even got
into stahls and i think that they still
have a lot of great uses to this day and
it should be said those uses are many
this video should not be considered an
exhaustive list by any means
but definitely
several of the exercises and tricks that
i first learned when i picked up wraps
that i think you might be into do bear
in mind that if you want to get really
far down this rabbit hole there's a
bunch of glow stringers you should go
check out because glow stringers have
really turned wraps into an art and a
science and we in the poi community are
definitely way behind our glowstringer
friends in that regard so the first
variation we're going to cover here is
actually the one that i just thought
looked the coolest when i first learned
how to do wraps and that is elbow wraps
in split time same direction the people
who first taught me wraps did this all
the time and there was something about
it that just looked so cool especially
when it was done on fire i realized that
we are at a different place in poi
history than we were when i first
learned this but there's just something
about the balance and symmetry of it
that i think looks super cool now i know
normally i throw a whole bunch of theory
and a trajectory out there when i
show you all a trick in this series
being like yes this sets you up for this
or this teaches you this important skill
this one just looks cool honestly i mean
it's helpful for the next trick on the
list but yeah this one just pretty much
looks cool so yeah i'm just going to
show you that one once again because i'm
a fan and you know
first year of spinning me would be proud
right now all right so the second
variation we're going to visit here is
actually kind of a variation on the
first one but it adds a little bit of a
twist and this makes it kind of a tongue
twister
see how i did that
this is an air wrap wrap so the idea
here is that you're basically entering
into an air wrap but you're also
aborting before the air wrap can
complete and then exiting back out of it
by doing those wraps around your elbows
it basically takes the first trick and
adds another layer to it and this one
you can find lots and lots and lots of
videos online of people finding cool
things that they can do with this
from bouncing only one poi at a time and
using it as a timing and direction
changing exercise
all the way up to doing some more
intricate stuff with bringing the poi
into inside planes that i frankly can't
do there's a lot of options here and of
course if you're in a place where say
you don't really have the exits on your
airwrap solid just yet you can totally
use this as a placeholder because if the
poi just go right back the way that they
came the exit is going to be a little
bit easier than trying to see through
small tip but hey you know if it helps
you through it helps you through all
right so before i lay down my final pick
for what comes next after you learn your
wraps i do have a huge favor to ask if
you've come this far it probably means
that you are into poi spinning and
learning poi tricks and guess what
that's the whole mission of my channel
so if you're having a good time and
enjoying this video i would really
appreciate it if you would leave me a
like and subscribe to the channel
that way you're the first to know when i
upload a new video and if you have a
moment i would really appreciate it if
you would leave me a comment with a
request for another poi trick to use in
this series for what comes next could be
something that you've just learned or
something that you want to learn either
which way most of the topics of these
videos come from suggestions like by
viewers like you so leave me one of
those and help me come up with the
videos that are going to help you
through your journey and now my number
one pick for what comes next after you
learn raps so this is going to sound
kind of weird but it is what i refer to
as the coin flip exercise and this
doesn't make a lot of sense as you're
watching it here so let me explain okay
so basically here's how this works if
you've got the top and bottom wraps on
both arms you can put together a unique
series of wraps that may never have been
performed by anyone else before here's
how
take a coin and you basically coat it so
that your head side is your left wrist
and your tail side is your right wrist
go ahead and flip the coin 10 times and
write down each result whether it be the
left hand or heads or the right hand or
tails once you have that sequence down
you get to go perform the sequence
yourself this is a great way to learn
transitions going back and forth between
when the poi are traveling in the same
direction versus opposite directions as
well as doing timing shifts
plus which it just looks really cool and
as i said if you take this out enough
places
this is more than likely an exercise
that nobody has ever done before simply
because the numbers add up that way so
it's a fun little drill that i'm a big
fan of and that's why it is my number
one pick for what comes next after you
learn wraps
[Music]
what did you think of my picks were
there wraps that you wish that i had
done i'm fairly certain that there are
this might even be one of the first what
comes next videos that i do a second
volume on so if you have suggestions for
other wraps you'd like to see me cover
please leave me a comment and let me
know i'd really appreciate it this video
would not be possible without the kind
support of all of these amazing people
right here these are my flow patrons
over on patreon and they along with the
people listed down in the description
help to make this video and all the
videos on this channel possible do you
like flow videos do you like what comes
next do you like my vlogs well guess
what i am on a mission to try and bring
poi spinning and flow arts to the wider
world and help people connect with their
brains and their bodies as creative
individuals so help me do it head on
over to
patreon.com drexfactorpoi you can do
that either by clicking on the link that
i have down in the description or by
clicking on the card that just popped up
if you're watching on youtube there you
can get access to a host of awesome
rewards such as early access to my
content or getting an exclusive lesson
delivered to your email inbox every week
that's only available to my patreon
subscribers so go check that out and i
hope you sign up please and thank you
one final note here sometimes if say you
have really hairy arms like i do you
might want to use some wrist coverings
they come in a variety of different
types out there and they look pretty
cool in themselves just because it'll
kind of take care of some of the road
rash that inevitably comes out of doing
all these wraps just a suggestion
in the meantime thank you all so much
for watching i'm going to include a link
to other videos in the what comes next
series down in the description as well
as up on screen if you are watching on
youtube have yourselves a great weekend
get out and flow and i will see you with
a new video on monday
peace